IT'S TIME FOR THE NEXT
GAME, HIGH MALL.
YOU KNOW, FINDING A PERFECT GIFT
FOR STONER IN YOUR LIFE CAN
BE TOUGH.
YOU'VE ALREADY GIVEN THEM THE
BLU-RAY OF "FIGHT CLUB" AND THAT
CROCHETED THROW PILLOW THAT
READS, IT IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT
YOUR DAD THINKS YOU ARE A
FAILURE, (BLEEP) THAT GUY.
NEVER FEAR, THE WEB IS FULL
OF DANK GIFTS FOR YOUR SMELLIEST
OF LOVED ONES.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU TWO
POT-THEMED PRODUCTS, AND FOR
250 POITNS, YOU TELL US WHICH
ONE IS REAL.
FIRST ONE: ON ETSY CAN YOU
GET A PIPE SHAPED LIKE PIKACHU
OR OLAF THE SNOWMAN FROM FROZEN.
RON.
>> I AM ASSUMING YOU GET BOTH
EASILY.
>> Chris: YOU HAVE TO PICK ONE.
>> OLAF BECAUSE HE'S VERY
BONG-SHAPED.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, LET'S FIND
OUT.
PIKA!
TOKEMON.
$49.95 FOR THAT.
GOT TO SMOKE THEM ALL.
HEY, CHRIS DON'T -- I HAVE A
GLASS BLOWING GOING.
>> Chris: OH YOU DO.
>> SO I CAN GET YOU CAN THAT FOR
$39.99.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, A BIG
LEBOWSKI MANGER SCENE FOR
CHRISTMAS OR A PILLOW SHAPED
LIKE A BAG OF DANK NUGS.
TEEJ.
>> ACTUALLY I SLEEP EVERY NIGHT
ON A BIG LEBOWSKI MANAGER SCENE
FOR CHRISTMAS.
... A MANAGER SCENE...
>> Chris: 4/20, BRO!
(APPLAUSE)
>> YOU KNOW WHAT? NOW THAT I
SEE THIS MANGER AND NOT MANAGER
-- I AM GOING TO GO WITH PILLOW
SHAPED LIKE A BAG OF DANK NUGS.
>> Chris: THE CORRECT ANSWER IS,
A PILLOW!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> THAT'S LESS THAN A PIKACHU
PIPE.
>> Chris: LAST ONE.
A STONER SEX GUIDE CALLED "SEX
POT" OR A STONER PARENTING GUIDE
CALLED "HOW TO RAISE A CHILL
DUDE."
RON.
>> I WAS WORKING ON HOW TO RAISE
A CHILL DUDE SO I AM GOING TO
ASSUME IT IS SEX POT.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, LET'S FIND
OUT.
"SEX POT"!
HOW TO GET IT ON!
>> FOR BONUS POINTS WHAT IS SEX
MOVE YOU'D FIND IN THIS BOOK.
STEVE AGEE.
>> THE BENSON INTERRUPTION.
IT'S WHEN YOU'RE HAVING SEX AND
CHRIS HARDWICKDOUB BENSON TEXTS
YOU AND ASKS YOU TO BE ON HIS
PODCAST.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS. T.J.
>> WHEN YOU'RE STARTING TO DOZE
OFF AND THEN DENY IT WHEN SHE
ASKS YOU IF YOU'RE DOZING OFF
AND THEN STOP HALFWAY THROUGH
TO ORDER RAMEN.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS.